before we get into that john that's
worth we see this morning that uh your
leader plans to publish a 14 000 word
essay which will tell us who he is what
he's about and what labour wants
wouldn't it be just simpler just to say
we're for
higher taxes or we are for
a different way of organizing health
service rather than giving us a lot of
philosophy
well leaders publish essays about their
core beliefs all the time it's not
unusual for a political leader to write
an essay for a think tank which is
associated
with their party
i i think
the broader point here is and i want to
put this in the broader context is that
i don't accept the premise of your
opening remarks i don't accept that a
government imposing a
punishing unfair tax rise on working
people
who are they also clobbering with
council attack rises with reasoning
treating their personal allowance and a
lot of them will lose 20 pounds a week
in the universal credit is somehow a
left-wing government and actually the
vote in parliament last week and the
vote in parliament coming up this week
is whether we support that tax rise it's
not a vote on the funding allocations
for the national health service of
course the labour party is always going
to want to see more money going into the
health service but our problem with what
has been announced this week is that it
is a punishing unfair tax rise that
won't deliver the health care that is
needed we won't see people treated
within 18 weeks again like they were
under the last labour government and it
certainly doesn't fix social care the
cap yes it limits the liabilities that
some people will pay out but only
benefits one in seven people what about
the other six in seven who see no
benefit you'll still have to pay top-up
charges and fees so you're still at risk
of losing your house so it fails on its
own terms
in the small print it suggests that
because of the way the financing works
council
council tax will go up or care homes
will go bust and there will still be
thousands upon thousands of people in
this country who don't get access to the
social care they need so i'm afraid i
gently and politely disagree with the
way in which you frame this okay um i've
allowed you to explain at length why you
think the government's wrong and i hope
that we've dealt with that point now
because i really want to talk about what
labour actually thinks
about some practical things
as well as some
broader political questions um first of
all are you going to go along with the
government's uh
likely decision to end the need for pcr
tests after travel uh if that's what
they decide to do so the health
secretaries seem to suggest uh earlier
on
well we'll
we'll have to see what the proposal is
when it comes before parliament we've
had some briefing into the newspapers
today
that certain elements of the coronavirus
act will be taken off the statute book
at first sight based on the briefing the
clauses which are going to be taken off
the statute book that looks like a
reasonable approach to me but obviously
we'll want to study the detail when it
comes to parliament because there have
been huge concerns about the way in
which that the coronavirus act has been
uh misused by the authorities and
ridiculous fines have been imposed on
people when they've been you know
sitting on park benches and so on that's
not what this legislation was aimed at
but obviously we'll want to study the
detail we can't just go off what we've
what has been briefed into sunday
newspapers because we want to take we'll
want to take a considered choice in the
round all right well you're you're open
to it okay let's talk about what labour
would do in relation to social care and
you've said
already we don't need to go back over
the tory proposals and all of that um
andy burnham your labour colleague wrote
in the newspaper this week my advice to
my party would be not to leave it too
long before presenting
a better uh proposal criticism of the
tory plan alone won't cut through unless
we say what we would do and he proposes
what he calls labour's opportunity to
end this injustice which is creation of
the national care service
ask all old older people to contribute
whether they need care or not and
what he has also said is that we might
take a labor government should take a
chunk of uh someone's property if
necessary are you up for all that
well let me tell you what our
alternative approach is to social care
first of all we need to expand access to
care and we need to expand eligibility
for accessing that care so we can
deliver the tailored personalized care
for people in their home so they can
stay in their home longer and not be
forced into a home at the moment 3 000
people a day are turned down for care
you'll have people watching the program
this morning trevor whose parents
perhaps have got dementia and they are
battling with a complex system day in
day out just to get some basic care for
their parents and they get turned down i
i don't want to be rude no but i don't
want to be rude but you're what you're
telling me is what's wrong
and what you wouldn't do
i've put to you what andy burnham has
been produced and i really just would
like you to say
i think that's a good idea or i don't
know no i think it's a bad idea no no
well
i am telling you what our care service
will look like because
how are you going to provide it which is
what burnham and i thought
about this yesterday how are you going
to get from here to there well
if you stop interrupting me i will tell
you well if
okay well you've just interrupted me
again trevor so if you expand
eligibility with a national framework
for expanding eligibility which is what
we want to see more people will access
care in their home and will not need to
go into a care home or go into a or be
delayed in hospital in a bed and not
able to get care out in the community
out in the community if you do that you
actually save money the ippr for example
has suggested you could save two and a
half billion pounds so there's a two and
a half billion pound saving that we will
reallocate to the front line of social
care secondly you need to raise
standards and quality in care there's 15
of care services are rated inadequate
the way in which you raise standards and
move away from these dehumanizing
15-minute visits where you have to make
a choice between having a warm bath or
having a warm meal or you're put to bed
at early evening not because you want to
but because the system tells you you
have to go to bed we want to end all
that by investing in staff so what we'll
do is we'll pay the staff a real living
wage lots of the staff get less than the
minimum wage at the moment we'll get rid
of these zero hours contracts that a
quarter of the staff are on and will
invest in their training
thirdly there's a number of carers in
this country who get no support
whatsoever we'll give them proper
respite support and fourthly we'll have
a plan for adults with disabilities
particularly adults with learning
disabilities and autism who are
currently today around two thousand of
them
glock in hospitals sometimes in the most
inhumane conditions of the victorian
asylum we are going to end that as well
on social care
of course may i ask you a question now
please
you've now given me a four-point program
uh part of which is to raise you think
two and a half billion
victories plan this week is raising 12
billion
where's your nine and a half billion
coming from
you know i'm telling you because we've
got a reform program we can release
savings but there are otherwise we can
really other ways we can really save
things nine and a half one of those
adults
every one of those adults in an
inpatient care unit with autism of
learning disabilities costs in the
region of two hundred thousand pounds if
we looked after those people in the
community it wouldn't be costing two
hundred thousand pounds per person
you're looking in the region of thirty
odd thousand pounds there's a saving
secondly the way in which we fund social
care in this country is now through
seven different funding streams and it
is delivered through different
mechanisms better care funds continuing
health care by bringing health and care
more closely aligned together so the nhs
and local authorities are planning care
in local areas you sweep away
bureaucracy and you can deliver market
and that's really important particularly
for people with dementia who are
currently bounced around the system and
don't get the care that they need so by
reforming care you can actually release
money to the front line